yes all right good
what's going on guys Lord addict here we
uh we we got some got some good stuff
for you guys man but the Lord's did go
out there and uh you know we played
redfall you know I let Cog go give a
little brief summary about the event
yeah man shout out to the good our good
friends at Bethesda and Arcane Austin
yeah we had a good time you know I had a
chance to take a look at Red fall behind
the scenes single player single player
version of it they were very key
distressed that shout out to Harvey
um and the team and uh yeah I guess we
gotta break this thing down so if I had
my brethruent with me yeah like old
school and uh yeah man we got a chance
to go behind the scenes and we're going
to talk about that with the realm
yeah first off I want to break down you
know the conditions of we did this uh
unfortunately lower Cognito and Lord
soft picked the same character so we
only give you the reference of one
character uh that's how you know that
none of this was was really thought of
because for some reason they both use
the same character too excited so we
gravitated to the funny yeah the funny
parties before it happened I was like
I'm sitting there getting to my station
got everything set up and I was just
like all right and in my mind I'm like
I'm taking Layla I'm gonna see you know
whatever and then I did think about it I
was like I'm looking up I'm like yo at
least five songs they go so we don't
take the same character but I couldn't
find him to find out that he's literally
across me I just couldn't see I was
across I was just on the other side of
them but the thing is you know what it
is that there was three three seats on
every side like every station had sort
of like three seats so Maddie sat down
[__] sat down when I went for that last
seat somebody already grabbed it so I'm
like damn all right I'm gonna go around
to the other side that's why I couldn't
find you yeah so that somebody snatched
that seat that was right next to you uh
Cox yeah okay so yeah yeah we wound up
taking the same character but we give
different perspective yeah so how we're
going to do this you know we've never
done nothing like this uh this is one of
our very first like previews to this
extent uh what we're gonna do is I
didn't play they did but I do have a
decent set of knowledge when it comes to
arcade games so you know I got a little
bit of questions for you guys we're
gonna go over one question at a time
first question I really want to ask you
is you know since you guys have had your
preview with just a single player let me
let me let me say that we only played
the single player of redfall there was
no Co-op features in in this particular
uh time when they were playing the build
they wanted to really emphasize look you
can play this game as a single player
and as a co-op feature we'll go into
that we have actual question on that but
I want you guys to explain to the realm
What type of game redfall is because I
know that you know we might know what
redfall is but I'm sure there's a lot of
people that you know gravitate in and
out of the gaming sphere they don't
really put the ear to the ground like we
do you know we'll start with soft soft
what redfall yeah so redfall is a like
you said a single or multiplayer Co-op
game
um where you're basically it's kind of
it's PVE right and you're you're put
into this town of redfall which is uh
kind of like it this this sort of
Vampire Apocalypse has happened in this
world and uh you're it's on you well
with the four specific characters that
you have access to to sort of uh well
the vampire the the sort of vampire
Insurrection that has happened there and
yeah and it and it's basically uh a PVE
uh either single player or multiplayer
experience that has you know touch
obviously the touches of what Arcane is
right so you have each character has
special powers that you can you know
it's a skill tree that you can sort of
improve upon and evolve throughout the
game and the gun play right and the
thing about it is that you know Arcane
isn't usually used known for their gun
play uh you know that death Loop was
really one of their first games that
they really really focused on Gunplay
and this would be the second one so it's
interesting that it it's a it's a
shooter but it also has a lot of the
elements that you expect from arcane
how do you feel about it Carl you know
coming from the background that you may
have dabbled a little bit I know you
played a little bit of that flute but
you ain't really jumped in head first to
an arcade game how did you feel uh
playing this how would you describe
redfall yeah open world uh Cooperative
uh campaign obviously you played the
single player version of mode um like
you said attic you know I am not the
arcade guy but say I'm kind of new to
these games and um you know for me I
think one of the things that kind of
stood out initially when we got there is
before we got a chance to play the
session you know Harvey Smith and the
team they kind of were talking about
what redfall is and the fact that the
single player campaign in their opinion
kind of represents what the Arcane
purist experience would be you know I'm
saying which is you know kind of this
immersive world with vampires and stuff
like that and um how you can kind of
interact with the world I think for me
you know the main thing was that you
know as far as how I felt about it like
I felt fun I felt like you know what I'm
playing felt fun and we I know we're
gonna get into details but more with
with the questions but I think that was
my main thing and I think they were very
clear to to make a separation that we
are not left for dead you know say like
we are not we are telling a single
player and and a Cooperative story and
we just wanted to let you know that
there's a distinction between both so
yeah that's just about my initial field
I thought it was interesting that they
told us that so you know I'm glad that
you brought that up when it comes to you
know the developers you know really
coming out saying what to not compare
this game to
is there a game that you've played in
the past that you feel like you could
compare this game to remotely do you
think it's so unique that there's not a
game you can compare it to we'll start
with Saul
yeah I think uh one of the things that I
compared it to in some ways was kind of
OverWatch uh because it does feel like
it is a a PVE sort of hero shooter where
each of the characters has like three
special moves that uh kind of fall into
the realm as you expect from like from
Arcane games like if you think about
corvo and the type of movesets he had it
Dishonored it's like that but then you
had the shooting aspect of it so to me I
it kind of felt like it was OverWatch
but in a PVE setting with story and
narrative sort of elements um kind of
even you know I haven't played a lot of
Destiny but I you know you guys do a lot
of PVE stuff in Destiny where you know
each of your characters it's it's a
little bit different right build wise
and stuff like that but it is that sort
of thing where you have specific powers
that are are useful in specific ways in
combat and I think that's what I sort of
compare it to
um yeah so for some a multiplayer
perspective definitely that from a
single player perspective uh and we'll
get into it uh it feels like it is the
the Arcane experience with more focus on
gun play
and less of a focus on the powers which
for me is a little bit disappointing
because I just feel like the the number
of powers each character has is limiting
but overall it is that experience so
yeah it's it's a little bit of all of
that
yeah I mean kind of like jumping off of
what's always say I think that you know
for me as a destiny player there was
some things that I felt intrinsically I
gravitated towards okay left bumper was
like my primary power you know in case
of Layla who I took it was kind of like
this you know Titanfall suck the bullets
up you know reflect them back kind of
power that she had and then right Bumble
was like this lift and you know you jump
into the air and you can kind of elevate
and then um both bumpers were like the
super button when she like brought her
boyfriend out and he's tearing stuff up
he was crazy on that in that respect so
the sensibilities to it would definitely
you had the abilities but I definitely
felt it was a lot of a lot of Gunplay
and the fact that they wanted to again
just for on transparency they had us um
we started not at the beginning of the
game the demo that we played was kind of
like in the middle of the game they gave
us kind of like Advanced weapons and
things of that nature so um yeah I I
just thought that the feel I can't
compare it to anything specifically only
because
the open world aspect of it right and
the fact that you know it is truly an
open world and we'll get into more
details we'll show you the questions a
fair like you know statement would be
it's hard to compare this game because
it was like Apex Legends like Apex
Legend was so different but so like
other games but you couldn't compare it
to other games but yeah yeah exactly
it's like putting the hero mechanics
into an arcade game exactly exactly yeah
when I said OverWatch I meant over like
a PVE version of OverWatch not PVP but
they're definitely that yeah and I think
to add on the distinction from me is
that even though like I said that's the
OverWatch and the other game a lot of
that is a hub world right the Hub and
you have to go transport this is no like
there is a an open world youth summer um
places you can go inside houses and
things like nature so that part is where
the separation for me is from the others
yeah all right so one thing I want to
really go into is I feel like arcane's
always done a well job on character
development from corvo to Colt they've
done a really good job at explaining
these characters and building as a
character through the game now when it
comes to redfall I know you guys only
played with the same character uh but
did you feel like going into there that
they're going to continue this trend in
redfall we'll start with cognito yeah I
mean I felt like the characters had a
lot of personality you know I mean I
felt like you know Layla who obviously
we both took and I drawn to the Frog man
I had to get the Frog I had to get I had
to see what she was doing yeah so yeah I
think that that proves even more that
she's the most unique character like
visually and you know personality wise
because that's the one people are drawn
to the moment they see that character
yeah absolutely right about that because
she is the other the other characters do
feel kind of like archetypes or whatever
she is like and we discussed this right
that where she is kind of the reason for
why the whole redfall event happens like
she is basically the patient zero that
they experimented on with some sort of
blood thing and from that sort of the
vampires were born or or actually
whatever happened with her blood was
used by someone else to sort of begin
the experiments that scientist moment
exactly exactly so she is the thing is
out of that experimentation she comes
out of it with telekinetic powers and
that's what gives her the lift and the
sort of the the the sort of uh what do
you call it the the shield that she's
able to throw stuff back and things like
that so yeah she is the most interesting
character and I have a feeling
story-wise she's going to be super
integral to the overall story of it too
yeah so you know talking to you solve
because you you've played the redfall
games uh uh you've played the Arcane
games you've played the Dishonored the
praise uh obviously Beth loop I don't
think he was a big fan of that but you
know what we'll go into with you is
the atmosphere of the game like I think
that
they've done not only character
development wise I would say atmosphere
above all even gameplay to a certain
degree they've always made all the
worlds that they've made feel very alive
and what I want to ask you is
off of playing the little bit you played
in redfall do you feel like they're
going to continue that you know that I
was it's kind of like a living world
like it's like it's it got its own pulse
the the the the stuff they do in
dishonored Where Cobra goes to these
characters and
I really enjoyed that and I think that's
the biggest thing that a lot of Arcane
fans do you think they're going to
continue that Trend with redfall I mean
just in a little bit that we played I
think they've already you know knocked
that out of the park you know that is
one of the apart from the gameplay stuff
that's the aspect of Arcane games that
are really exciting to me this the the
World building the fact the feeling that
this world is sort of lived in and you
know the environmental storytelling
where they're never really telling you
telling you what happened you can walk
out and and into the world and sort of
figure it out on your own and they do
things like you know you know NPCs will
talk to you and give you little stories
they'll they'll give you little missions
to go on
um you'll walk into a place where you'll
see like blood all over the place and
and dead bodies and you'll find a note
and it'll give you an idea of what
happened there
um yeah all of that is in there in the
same way in the way that you expect from
any Arcane game that you'd expect from a
Dishonored or a prey or a death Loop all
of that stuff is in there and that's one
of the first things that I went to look
for like when I started playing I I the
way I play these games is that I play
them slowly ridiculously I like to go in
and sort of try to break the world and
see what I can do and get away with but
I do like talking to the NPCs and just
looking at the environment and just
seeing the world that they've crafted if
I get a sense of place and and time when
I look at that world and I have to say
they really knocked it out of the part
there's one specific instance uh one of
the first places that I visited was the
boat docks and I went to the boat docks
and when I get there there's literally
uh so basically whatever happened in
redfall the vampire event called
basically everyone is stuck in redfall
they can't get out of it of red fall so
one of the things that is physically
blocking people from leaving is that you
know whatever this Vampire Apocalypse
caused the ocean to turn up on itself
and it's literally Frozen in time so at
the boat docks you see this wall of
water Frozen in Time with boats cracked
in half in the middle of it
um all kinds that's a beautiful scene
when I saw it I was talking to Maddie
about it I was like oh my God God I
can't believe this thing that I saw he's
like what what was that I was like the
boat docks it was just it's something he
didn't see at all in his playthrough and
it was this thing I was like okay the
idea of environmental storytelling the
place and time stuff the thing that
makes the place feel alive that is super
alive and well in this game and it's
extra impressive because in other Arcane
games though the environments are
smaller right they're they're more
creative they're more sort of curated
this is an open world so you have to try
to maintain that level of interest in
terms of World building across a bigger
landscape and so far what I've seen
they've done a a fantastic job of it
really excited about that so so Carl I
know that you haven't really played too
many of their games to really compare
the atmosphere to other games but what I
like about talking to you about is like
you're coming in with like a a clean
slate like you you're coming in there
with not really boss because I'll be
real mean so we're behind super biased
yeah like what I want to hear from you
is did you feel like off you know I
think think it was like you said like an
hour and a half of gameplay did you feel
like it was an atmospheric kind of game
did you feel like you were drawn to it
what's your what's your thoughts on it
yeah no good question I I definitely
felt drawn to it I mean you know you
start off kind of like you start off in
like a firehouse kind of station you
could tell this is where they they're
congregating there's obviously some
survivors in there you go out first
thing I want to give a credit to is the
art style at first when I saw red fall
initially in first looks I wasn't too
sure about how graphically I would like
it to be honest and one thing is I
really started to appreciate the art
style actually playing it and I was like
oh no this looks cool there was like a
picture of like four oh I was walking
through the fire department there's a
picture of like four distinct I guess
captains captains that were like they
used to run the place so I don't know if
they died or they still alive but NPCs
looking at them so I stood up there and
looked at them I was like okay what's
going on and then I went out into the
world you know solved with One Direction
I went another way and then the first
thing I noticed was just like okay you
could tell something has happened in
this town this is Siri serious effects I
saw cultists kind of scouting seeing
what's going on you know the first
things that I noticed was these certain
areas that had like a a blue mist around
certain areas right certain areas when
you walk around about they saw a red
mist and and the Blue Mist kind of was
very intriguing like I went into it to
see what's going on in there whatever
whoever's in there the vampires are in
power they are buffed and I just thought
it was cool when I walked in it was like
oh you're coming to sacrifice yourself
to me today and I was like oh I'm
talking smack I probably talking mad
strong so I was like oh I like this you
know saying so it was dope and then you
know attic you would appreciate this the
redness you know it reminded me of kind
of like that State of Decay blood heart
blood pack kind of energy but like
different more more stress because the
minute you jump into it you are
physically getting hurt and I was just
like yo I can't be in here and I I guess
you got to find like a blood pack thing
and maybe get a UV like we found out
after how I was supposed to deal with
that but during I was just like yo this
is crazy so it did to what Sava said the
the thing for me when I really felt the
atmosphere was you know I'm looking
around I'm seeing the houses and not
every house you go to but there was a
couple I'm like okay that window's open
on the second floor I use Layla got up
on the left got to the top crawled it
and I went inside and I was kind of
doing like a breaching clear room the
room and it was tension you see blood
stain flaws you've seen bodies like
vampires did stuff in there like it was
crazy that I ended up encountering some
vampires and it it brought the tension
up so the thing about it is it made me
more not that it was a scary game but
the tension the atmosphere really I
didn't think I was going to get that for
red four I thought I was gonna be yeah
just go around straight action yeah yeah
what you're describing
is literally the foundation of arcade
games they all have that okay like just
random Windows opening because the
reason they started implying that is
because you know you'd have spells like
blink you know yeah you could consult
time and you would use these blink
spells to uh to maneuver around these
maps to get to higher areas so and the
only way to really truly do that is if
they wanted to have that many ways to do
a certain thing to access you have to
give access to certain areas you only
can get to with blink or another type of
spell yeah so so blink Cog is like a
night crawler power oh okay okay yeah
yeah so
um well he's gonna say so sorry no no I
said I just wanted to because I don't
know if he knew what blink was I'm glad
you explained it
all right so what I want to go over next
is obviously the the main antagonist the
main creature of this game is vampires
and uh I think we can all agree vampires
in terms of Mythology it's one of the
it's one of the loves and I think people
love
this form of a creature they love every
aspect about it and what I was curious
is how they're going to portray a
vampire because uh multiple Medias do it
differently and what I want to know from
you guys off of you know playing a
little bit of the game is how did you
feel like they did vampires we'll start
with Saul
yeah so what was interesting about this
game is that you know when you look at
the art style and you look at the the
video and stuff you've seen of the
vampires they look kind of like classic
vampires right they fangs and very
angular features even pointy ears some
of them have like like like their
collars popped up like when you would
think about of a Dracula or whatever but
the funny thing is that story wise these
are not vampires of Legend This is not
Dracula this is not these are vampires
that were created by science some sort
of scientific experiment you know mixed
with the cult stuff probably
um that went awry and all of a sudden
these vampires were born and they have
this entire hierarchy and all this stuff
so in every sense of the word they're
vampires except from what you
traditionally expect them to have been
created from right so that's super
interesting because again as a story
beat I'm interested to see what the heck
why did why did this you know person who
wanted to do this why why did they even
want to do this did they even know that
vampires were gonna come of this or was
this just some big accident that went
awry and uh and you know and this is the
end result of it but the fact that it's
not vampires you know Vlad tepish and
and you know and you know Bella Lugosi
is none of that it's none of that it's
scientifically created Vampire so it's
it's super interesting and I'm excited
to see how the story plays out in that
regard
yeah how you feel called because I know
you know you come from I would say my
era uh my generation was more about you
know the werewolves I feel like you guys
probably had more of the Vampire scene
uh you know Dusk Till Dawn stuff like
that I ain't never seen those ones he's
gonna be real with you guys but how do
you feel they handle vampires I thought
it was cool I thought it was cool I
think for me it was more the Allure of
how they fight and and because what I
encountered the cultists should be told
you know the AI wasn't I felt the
strongest there like yeah they would
spot me yeah they may see me you know
but they to me they only became a threat
when it was more of them and then one of
them rang alarm then it was like oh man
it's hard this is hard to deal with but
individually it's like I get you out of
here and the funny thing is that's
arcade games too nice it's hitting the
ball it's hitting the check box for me
if that's how they always do but the
thing for me with the vampires was just
the way they attack because you know
some you see them in the chilling side
some are awake and like when you see
them and they when they're ready to
engage they let you know you're gonna
hear it and then they are on you and I
love the teleport like so you're
shooting it they're out the way it's
almost like these quick teleports to
close the distance and get you and the
last thing you know for me which really
solidified more of the gum play was the
fact that you know when you're shooting
get vampires into stuff like you can't
kill them they go into a down state and
then when they're in that down state
that's when you gotta get the [__] you
get the the your knife on it or the
bayonet you gotta you gotta stab them
with the stake and then they turn the
dust that part was so visceral it felt
so good so the engagement with the
vampires is what really what excited me
as I didn't expect that I was just
expecting you know shoot them up pow pow
whatever whatever but yeah yeah it was
on it was on when they was there and I
loved that aspect there was one time I
got caught out of pocket I was in the
house and I thought it was just one of
them and they was kind of in a sleep
position and I was like yeah I'm so get
him and then there was another one I was
like oh it was on I was I was fumbling
out you know get out of here the same
yeah okay yeah the same thing happened
to me it was in our and the little bit
that I got to play after we had our
interview yes yes yeah we have an
interview going live as well yeah more
content from the Lord more content from
the Lord
um and it was I went into a museum it
was a museum and I went to the second
floor of the museum and the museum was
beautiful like everything encased in
glass you can see the reflections coming
off a bit it was very well preserved but
you could tell there was and like like
you said Cog I walked in and you hear
the vampires whispering and the cult is
talking so you know there's drama in the
building but you can't see it until I go
up to the second floor and I tripped
something so some kind of like some kind
of trap or alarm that set everybody
going crazy right and the awesome thing
about it when the vampires come out the
cultists come out first those are the
pawns yeah throw them out and so you
deal with them and then the vampire is
this slick though because they're
powerful but they're smart too they
started like they were like all right I
think once the cultists sort of take the
aggro right we're gonna jump in and that
combat scenario was very fun because
when you're dipping your dick sort of
Dipping dodging between like the the
glass cases and the glasses break in and
stuff like that I was like Wow again it
was again the sense of time and place
coupled with like okay how how do these
vampires fit into this environment in a
way that makes sense that makes it
believable that they've taken over this
town they're just not kind of proxies is
standing in place it is very cool
because everywhere that you go in this
world you can tell the devastation that
the vampires have brought on it it's
blood it's all kinds of stuff so yeah
it's the vampire representation here
although different is very very cool
okay so the biggest question I I think
we can all say when it comes to Red
Falls throughout their whole marketing
is whether or not this is built on the
foundation of a single player game or
Co-op experience game I feel like they
really marketed a lot with that Co-op at
the beginning and then they kind of like
brought that back a little bit to show
you know this isn't just a multiplayer
game uh you know they had famous things
where they didn't like people comparing
it to something like um
so what I want to ask you guys is
playing this is just a single player
game uh do you feel like this could be
played as either because obviously we
haven't played the uh the co-op
experience but I think we can generally
give an idea of how that's gonna go we
all have different abilities uh but what
I want from you guys since you played a
decent portion uh which hour and a half
is that really disappointed or not but
you played that I want to know if you
feel like with that single player if
this game is going to be good on both
Dynamics so we'll start with Carl
yeah that's a good question I'm not sure
I'm not sure because it's In fairness
you know they put us in the mid-level
farther in the game we weren't at the
beginning right so to me the first thing
I got to do is I look at my Powers I
went straight to you know start menu
okay what abilities do I have with the
character and then there's like a mini
skill tree right so I'm like okay
there's certain things I could level up
things that nature then the second thing
I looked at was okay what weapons I have
and like the traditional Destiny you
know it was like a three weapon cycle
with the Y button kind of format and
then I also looked at okay you know
these color guns whether they be on you
know gold kind of like almost like an
exotic kind of in my mind you know
there's the legendaries so different
levels of guns gun power things of that
nature walking around the game you know
I was playing it with my looter
sensibilities you know killing things
looking up scoring in the houses
searching you know body searching you
know backpacks and trying to get
resources so there's a part of me that's
like you know I had some weapons that
was super powerful they were like I had
some you know single shot stake shooter
that could kill a vampire in one shot
clearly I'm not supposed to have this
and the devs stay ready to clear like
we're gonna give you a bunch of things
so there's a part of me that if I
started this from the beginning you know
less skill tree less weapons does it
feel more grounded because I have to
admit addict like I did feel op
sometimes like I was just body and dude
you know what I'm saying like it was it
less like I get I got completely jumped
I didn't feel that aspect so I think
that's the thing I think I'm gonna defer
to solve because obviously you guys play
you know the the Arcane games and what
they're known for these enriched single
players but that's the Cooperative guy
you know what I'm saying I felt they
were solid I felt it was competent I
felt that I liked you know what I played
I felt it was immersive enough for me in
an open world but again I'm not coming
from the mindset of an arcade arcade guy
that knows that's the reason I'm talking
we'll get to solve in a second
we can't give it I realistic answers on
this the reason I want to really you
know push back a little bit on that call
I feel like redfall has some of the
sprinkles of Destiny you know uh you got
an ability move kind of a class move and
then you got your super yes
um
you take that experience that you did
and there's three other people doing it
with you do you think that would be an
enjoyable experience in general oh yes I
can tell like this game was going to be
fun with abilities because you can see
you know how you can we didn't even
really talk about the other characters
but I like I have Remy who's like this
combat engineer she's got this little
robot and the robot yeah they was
explaining how like that robot could
distract enemies can also put like a
healing thing so in my mind I'm like
okay she's the Warlock
but she got a little buddy and then she
got things that she could heal then it
was like saw was it the sniper sniper
was Jacob yeah right not Jacob I believe
Maddie took him in in the demo that's
who mad at each other yeah he's got this
cloak thing that can make invisible he's
got this eye thing going on and then the
funny one was what division and he's got
the eagle too like the the right that
that can sort of pinpoint people's
locations yes okay I saw a super when I
was editing uh the interview and he's
got got like kind of like a Dutch uh
what's that dude from DC
um Deadshot or oh okay dude with the gun
yeah yeah they do that Will Smith played
uh yeah get shot that shot where he'll
like bring up his sniper and then he'll
just start shooting everyone's head
because it's super yeah yeah actually it
was a raven not a not an eagle and then
the last one was the uh the influencer
the vendor YouTube different the
YouTuber yeah he took a crypt was it a
crypto uh cryptologist yeah and he's
he's the dude that's always believed in
the Legends and vampires and stuff like
that and he's like he's he's stuck in
red fall but he's like he he feels he
feels like he's been Justified and
believing all of this stuff and he's
like he's kind of happy to be there in a
weird way like I'm gonna I'm gonna show
them like you know what I mean yes yeah
so yeah he had the teleportation joy and
he had the like one of his supers was
like this UV light that could really
like stop so basically your question yes
you know this game I feel like if you're
playing with four you know each has
those unique abilities that others will
take advantage I know people are going
to take advantage of lately let me put
your lift down here your elevator thing
so I can get on top of the building so I
can get for verticality and try to take
things out and and all the other
accounts and support powers and stuff as
well I can see combo abilities like uh
the the chick you guys played I think
you said Layla uh combining with the
sniper and her using her thing to shoot
him up into a position where he can see
more people to get his super off so I
can see it working out um you know one
thing I do want to talk about is I think
we can all gray here especially me and
Carl coming from Destiny uh background
the way guns feels is extremely
important in games and I think a lot of
people either hit and miss some people
don't care and I feel like some people
kind of like go towards other areas of
the game and they don't really take that
part as serious and I think people don't
some devs don't realize the importance
of how a gun feels how it sounds uh and
just overall gun gameplay in general uh
so what I want to ask you guys is off of
you know using the weapons in redfall
how did it feel we'll start to solve
yeah I thought I feel really good I mean
I think we you know with with death Loop
they they kind of lean more into the gun
play right more than they usually would
in an Arcane game and I think this goes
even further into that I think the guns
from the very beginning they felt like
super unique a lot of them have uh you
know kind of additions you can add to
them like you know like shoot out
multiple stakes and stuff and and sort
of upgrades like that that make them
feel really cool but in terms of how
they feel like yeah I I thought they
felt really good I got you know Kickback
when I was shooting a submachine gun I
got a kickback when I was shooting uh uh
a shotgun the the pistols felt good so
the guns really felt like it was an
evolution an improvement from what we've
seen from them before because I really
do think it's it's a bigger part of this
game than I would argue any other game
up until now even death Loop
um so yeah I think I think they did a
really good job with that and I think uh
you know when I look at some of my sort
of criticisms and worries about the the
lack of the lack of overall sort of
powers that you would see in um in in
Arcane games especially from just
character to character since they each
only have three I think it's it's an
interesting balance when you look at
kind of this the the sort of upgrade
path for guns and stuff like that and
how the guns sort of improve over time
and you know over just you know being
more powerful being able to take more
ammo and stuff like that but just cool
sort of additions like I said like the
the stake shooter and stuff like that
that can also add to that sort of Arcane
feel of being able to sort of to
manipulate the battlefield and the world
with your powers and now with the guns
in conjunction it feels like it's state
like they tried something new with that
but I definitely feel that the gun play
is something that was integral to
building this game and if and it you can
tell off the bat that they worked on
that
all right Carl coming from a destiny
background such as myself yes
um I think we can agree Destiny probably
has some of the best if not the best
gameplay in the industry and so with
that being said
how did you feel playing redfall in
shooting its weapons in the game yeah it
felt good it felt good that obviously
like you said we got to preface it you
know I'm used to the creme de La Creme
you know bungee you know shout out to
343 even you know I'm saying like that
that that that that just that precise
moment to moment Gunplay that the feel
it I'm never gonna say it's that level
but I was pleasantly surprised to say it
felt good and it felt competent it felt
like yes this is enjoyable this feels
good the weapons feel distinct um if I
had to nitpick a little bit again I
don't know if they don't have it but
what I would like to see is if there's
any melee up close kind of weapons you
know because there were times when I
like that situation I I bit off more
than I could chew inside the house of
the vampire's Army and you know it would
be interested if they had that you know
because I think Bailey would be fun in
that game if they did you know but um as
far as gun play yes yeah I I again the
the the weapons felt the stick they felt
good it they shot well I didn't feel
like and this doesn't have I think one
of my fears coming into was impact right
I wanted to see like how like because I
remember some of the trailers didn't
really win me up after about the early
first time you see red 4 announce type
trailers like it didn't really feel like
I guess this gameplay gonna be but I
felt really solid when I actually played
it and I was like nah this is this is
serviceable and I'm just curious to see
what more in the Arsenal they have how
more creative they they go and um yeah
again if arcade if y'all have melee
weapons please let me know because that
would be I'd like to get the the boy the
jigging and the cotton and the Stomp and
I like that if you give me if they take
a little bit of Gears energy Coalition
energy when it comes to like chainsaw
really go with it that would really take
it to the next level for me imagine
Layla like having a melee attack where
she like kind of like it would charge
where she grabs them with for
telekinesis and like just breaks them
yeah yeah that's what I want to see them
get super op like yes I want more
visceral you know especially because
when you think about your human beings
fighting vampires but you you know you
have the audacity to roll up on them and
slap them or punch them like that's what
I want to see right I want to see that
yeah or or you know it'll be cool if
like you can break like you you there's
an ability where like you grab things
around you and make it to like Stakes to
just stay without just Chuck them at
them yeah like I mean yeah my mind
started racing when I saw like kind of
like what you could hopefully do with
this stuff right with this camera
all right so let's cop uh we we gotta
talk man uh being the other person that
plays Destin we know about builds we
know when it comes to build stuff how
important it is to a lot of different
games out obviously we can't compare
this to Destiny because this is a
different type of style of game uh but
going in here and seeing some of the
types of you know Exotics so I don't
know what they call them in here uh the
different colored guns um I didn't I
don't know if that has different forms
of armor with different stats you know
break the the build format you know the
Rarities and stuff down that's in
redfall yeah the first thing you'll
notice is the weapon the weapon
distinctions you know the different
archetypes of guns you know shotguns I
believe there were some like
semi-automatic weapons I was using um
obviously I told you about the more
powerful weapons which kind of like um
grenade launcher style that shoots
Stakes there was a UV B ring which I
didn't know how to use correctly you
spoke to batty afterwards he actually
figured out how to utilize UVB correctly
and to get through those Red Mist areas
that had those blood heart kind of
things that were really enabling and
damaging you when you when you go
through so um I think yeah the the the
weapons itself fine as far as builds
though
I'm not short there because it felt this
is where I would defer to solve at the
arcade hardcore is that that felt felt
simplistic to me because they were like
yeah just killed trees but they were
like basic it wasn't like it's funny
because I just played Diablo and now I'm
like seeing all these extensions right
right way that skill that you sound like
oh yeah I get where they going now you
know what I'm saying so this felt you
know how many of them still order solves
uh good points which it felt like
they may have made a conscious decision
if they were extensive in the past to
the games like did you like it it's a
massive skill tree it may they may have
made a design decision to say okay we're
going to limit a couple of these per
character and split them among and make
it from The Cooperative standpoint as
opposed to each individual kind of like
Layla having this all expansive things
like I felt like that part they they
didn't go super hard with because as a
person who likes builds who likes to the
minutia of messing with little perks and
things like that I didn't see that
aspect and I'm hoping there's more to it
but from what we play at that point I
would say yeah that the skill tree felt
a little simplistic and um I'm just
curious as far as like I don't remember
correct me for a while I don't remember
seeing any kind of armor stuff I
remember so yeah I don't remember yeah
definitely weapon stuff no armor stuff
yeah I just seen like weapon stuff and
skill tree stuff so that's where I lean
I see where saw was coming from with the
hero shooter kind of energy as opposed
to like this deep
rpg-esque skill tree-esque even
outrighters I would say had a way more
deeper skill tree standpoint I think
that because this is preset characters
with abilities there's only so much you
can do in the military care uh uh
building characters now they could have
made it more like Borderlands and give a
little bit more options from what you
guys are saying but I do feel like this
particular game because there's four
people and you're building off of their
characters which you know we we don't
know everything about the game so that
there could be some some you know
in-game content kind of stuff where you
unlock you know newer abilities I don't
know uh that's that's complete
speculation but you know solve from what
you played of it you know you coming
from a Arcane background too I'm curious
to hear you got your opinion on you know
whether or not you could play these
unique character differently or do you
think they kind of I want you to play in
one line one way
well I think if my biggest criticism of
what I played would be that right that
as someone who comes from playing you
know a lot of Arcane games when you look
at a character like a corvo or an Emily
or even like a Morgan in prey and uh of
course Colt and deathly but when I
forget cool
um you know the skill trees are usually
six or seven deep right uh in terms of
their powers and then those skills
evolve over time to make them even more
powerful even more versatile so by
separating uh you know amongst four
characters each of them getting three
different skills it kind of feels like
when you put them all together you get
kind of one corvo or one Emily or one
cult
um so in that regard that's that's where
my criticism comes from that it feels
limiting in that regard that you know
the game is definitely competent and
playable as a single player game but if
you're if you're more of the Arcane type
player and you want to focus on your
powers instead of the gun play as much
it's going to be limiting because you're
going to have those three skills those
three those three skills have a tree
that you could you know you could
improve upon and expand upon throughout
the course of the game but just they let
us kind of look at the skill tree it's
not like a it's not like a blocked off
skill tree you can't see where the
evolution is going so when you look at
like the final evolution of the skill
tree right it it it it they don't really
evolve into Super interesting versions
of themselves like for with Emily the
telekinetic uh sort of elevator that she
has the evolution is that you get like
another one of those right and it just
shoots you up higher and stuff like that
the same with with the uh with the sort
of the umbrella Shield whereas now you
can absorb more more
um damage and throw it back out so it is
that sort of it's a natural evolution of
those Powers but when you think about it
in terms of how you I like to play in
these worlds it's limiting because you
know not every single character has a a
sort of like emotion uh Power not every
character has a stealth power right so
it's going to be a mix and match sort of
thing so when you play from character to
character it's going to be limiting
where I think you're going to get the
ideal
um Arcane experience is if you do play
it in four player co-op with you know
every single player playing as one of
the different characters utilizing all
the different powers and then seeing how
that comes together and and you know
with a four player PVE sort of thing
where you know you can learn how to
synchronize powers and like you said
before like Layla throwing down the the
sort of elevator for the sniper to jump
up and get higher because he naturally
can't get higher and stuff like that so
using those powers in conjunction to
have some some really cool moments but
from us from Individual characters so
far at least with Layla right I don't
know how the other ones play or evolve
at least with Layla it just seems like
no matter how much you evolve those
those abilities you're still going to be
limited to a certain type of of gameplay
type right so they're they're in there
goes you know where the guns are
integral now to to this game right so
that's my my criticism of it but uh
it it just makes me worry about the
longevity of the legs that the game has
as a single player thing more than
anything it makes me excited for what
the multiplayer can be because when you
get players you know these these players
that get in there they're pros and they
really want to get everything out of the
gameplay you're going to see some
amazing scenarios with people using all
these characters and and doing some cool
stuff you know I always think about when
I play Dishonored and and started
watching the the corvo videos on YouTube
and blink videos and him you know these
these players just jumping from person
to person murdering them and it's like
it's this amazing sort of Symphony of
death
um that's kind of like what I want to
see from this game and I think it has
that ability in multiplayer I'm not as
confident in the single player aspect
though just kind of so just to double
down one quickly to what's always saying
too is that
my concern with the single player is a
little different in the sense that I
definitely hear what you're saying in
all valid points but I I I wanted to
note that I was surprised that like when
I try to get as being soft call or
Mercury murder on which we play we in
the cut and I had to drop on a couple of
cultists so you're doing you know attic
you go behind I was waiting for like the
press to right analog in
you know what I'm saying the jiggle man
I didn't see that so I was like okay
they're really leading into this into
the gun player it's a gun play right and
that was the thing that surprised me
just like the the stealth coming you can
do stealthy things but I I wanted to see
if they were going to really lead into
it I felt that part surprised me not
being in a single player but that was
wrong yeah I'm glad you mentioned that
because that is that was super
disappointing for me I know Maddie
mentioned as well it is that thing of
like
these when you think about the immersive
Sim it's the RPG elements it's the
stealth elements it's the action
elements all coming together as one and
allowing you to sort of play it any
which way you want right you can play
you can play it straight in any one of
those three types of elements or
whatever the case may be or you can mix
and match them and and all of that is
valid when we saw that and I the same
thing happened to me I got the drop on
two cultists I was above them I dropped
them behind them quietly they had no
idea I was there I creeped behind them
and nothing and nothing I got up on them
I didn't get any prompt or anything like
that and they just turned around and I
wound up having to shoot them in the
face
um so that was disappointing because I'm
like man what okay so what are you
telling me here about this game yeah
yeah you know it was different and it
was like yeah I know I'm going along
because I've got to be thinking but the
other thing is where it real where the
switch flip for me and what what I think
they were trying to do or what they're
showing me is that when it became the
shooter it was like okay if I don't
eliminate all of them
then one can ring an alarm bring others
and then it becomes problematic for me
so right I think it was just I don't
know if it was design choice or wherever
that's where they go but they didn't
lean into that that stealth part that
that he was saying yeah it actually
we're gonna work we're about to talk
about Stealth um I feel like arcane's
been very good throughout the years with
Dishonored you know uh I didn't play a
whole lot of prey I'm assuming there are
stealth mechanics in there to a degree
and definitely where you could play the
game going in there guns blazing
throwing spells around I remember there
was uh spells you could do where you
could slow time down Pull someone in
front of their own bullets yeah there
was a lot of things you can do and you
know their previous games how would you
feel they're doing in the stealth
Department we'll start with Saul first
because he's played uh the previous
stuff
so like we were saying like there is
it gives it feels like the stealth
mechanics that the game does have are
more sort of for you literally to be
able to get around certain situations
stealthily and not use it offensively as
well like when Cog talks about Mercury
murder that for us that is the ability
to use stealth to get the drop on your
opponents but kill them anyway yes yes
yes yes yes it's not about doing the
ghost run it's about getting a drop on
them and murdering them from behind
that's all right so that so that's where
I sort of felt that this fell short
because it does not have that in the
same way at least from what we saw again
that was very telling that we were able
to get the drop on these uh NPCs and
then there'd be no sort of button prompt
or anything for you to kill them
stealthily so I know there is one which
is the character that has the stealth
cloaking I forgot who it is I think that
was Jacob the it's Jacob the sniper yeah
so again you can you if you go into you
can walk through the front door of a
place says invested with infested with
vampires turn your your stealth cloak on
and you can get around them right and
then go try to do whatever objective you
have to do in that place and try to get
out and play stealthily that way but
that is that is a very defensive sort of
ghost run type of way to play and it
doesn't feel like it's giving me a lot
of offensive options in terms of in
terms of the stuff like you can you can
go into stealth and kill a bunch of
cultists quietly like just shoot them in
the face and be standing in front of
them and they can't see you it's that
sort of stuff but the idea of being able
to to get the drop on them and kill them
with specific animations they've created
for that sort of stuff the stuff that I
expect from like a splinter cell or
again other Arcane games it was was kind
of disappointing not to see that and I
don't know if maybe some other character
does have that right and maybe uh you
know a Layla or Jacob doesn't have that
what else with Layla we didn't see that
right um so that was disappointing but
again uh Maddie was playing as Jacob and
he he didn't get that either
okay so Carl uh you know I'm sure you
played a lot of stealth mechanic uh
orientated games in the past
um when it comes to
their type of games normally they go
that you know you can you get sneak up
behind someone get rid of them they
actually have abilities where you can
get rid of them or if I remember
correctly and Dishonored you could
actually pick them up and take them
somewhere and just drop them so
um
they just disappeared the moment they
just disappeared so how did you feel the
options that Arcane gave you in redfall
to have more of a stealth approach on
certain uh encounters yeah that was one
of my few criticisms you know that I was
just like I didn't feel they lead into
that that this was definitely more of
the open world shooter you know I mean
and this is a different this is you know
hero shooter abilities things of that
nature but I didn't feel like yeah like
unless like again it's character
specifically we just didn't see certain
mechanics that wasn't present to us in
the demo I didn't feel that and that's
you know that's going to be received
differently you know I mean by people
people who are looking for that romp you
know that may not bother but for the
stealth stealth gang you know he was
like oh man maybe you missed a little
opportunity yeah something in there so
yeah that's pretty much what I was so
I've said it best already
okay so you know we're going to go ahead
and wrap this up with one last question
it's going to be to solved you have
played a lot of these arcade games
um there's a lot of arcade fans that are
very nervous that they're not seeing
some of the elements that they love in
their previous titles in this what what
is your message to them about whether or
not they should try redfall off of what
they've seen being RK fans yourself
well I think they should absolutely try
redfall no matter what because I no
matter how I end up feeling about the
game you have to commend them for trying
to sort of stick to their DNA while
expanding upon it in some ways right
it's you know a lot of their DNA is here
whether it be from the storytelling the
World building
um to the to the the the powers and
those types of mechanics they're just
leaning more into the gun play and but
they're not leaning into it in a cheap
way they it's obvious that they've
worked hard on that and they've worked
hard on creating that Synergy between
the gun mechanics and and the the
classic Arcane like powers and stuff
like that so I would say
no matter what this is an exciting step
for them whether they you know they hit
it out of the park and they really you
know they really nail The Landing is
left to be seen but I appreciate them
continuing to try to uh evolve their
formula
um from what I saw it really is an issue
of I just think I feel that I'm going to
be limited as a single player gamer with
the limited amount of powers each
character has um just from what I've
seen I could be wrong and I hope that
I'm wrong but from what I've seen it
just feels like I'm gonna play this game
four times right with each with a
different character to get this the
sense of what their powers give me in
terms of a variety out in the open world
and in combat I'm gonna do that and I'm
gonna hope that that is enough for me to
feel fulfilled as having played an
Arcane game right as opposed to a
shooter
um where I do think the game I'm excited
for people to get their hands on the
game and play is the multiplayer stuff
and make no mistake about it
it is a competent single player game and
I appreciate them for sticking to that
at the same time I do feel the game was
built for multiplayer and to get the
true Arcane experience out of this game
I think the ideal way to play would be
to be played you know for human players
each player you know playing one of the
different characters using all 12 of
those abilities in Synergy to create
something special uh when you're out
there in the open world fighting
vampires and stuff and taking on combat
scenarios I think that's where you're
really going to see the arcaniness of
the game
um and I'm excited for that because I
don't know that I've ever seen them
attempt something like that that's a big
deal to try to get that sort of synergy
in a PVE game where they're still trying
to tell you a story
um you know we've seen that sort of
synergy when you see like you know
OverWatch videos and how they use all
the powers together and stuff like that
and that's awesome but this is a
different beast and it's never quite
it's never really been done before so
I'm excited to to see if they they nail
that land ending and players really
gravitate to that type of gameplay
because I would be disappointed if
people just be like oh I don't really
care about the powers let's just shoot
and I'm sure they built it so that you
it would be a fun experience in that way
as well but I think for them as well as
for me as an Arcane fan the ideal would
be that people use the guns and the
powers in synchronicity in a way that
makes it feel super special like I want
to see those crazy videos on YouTube
with people going crazy with the power
so that's what I'm excited about that's
what I'm a little nervous about but
we'll see but overall
play the game because this no matter
what they're trying something different
I think there are super special elements
to it
yeah I think pretty much what you're
saying is like look it's our arcade game
it's just because of the way that they
went with this direction in redfall
they're trying new things they had to do
things differently than they normally
would do because this way doesn't make
sense to have those old mechanics to
their to to the law in this game because
then this game would suffer because when
you try something different especially a
four player campaign like they're doing
with a co-op experience can't do the
same laws that you would do in a single
player experience because then the
co-op's not going to feel like a co-op
it's not going to [__] a co-op and you
got to remember two open world yes
Arcane games aren't open world for the
most part they're you know they they
give you they kind they they can be wide
spaces right but all of those spaces are
still created and crafted like we were
talking before to give you the options
oh this window's open oh this door down
here is open uh there's Ledges
everywhere I can blink here but link
there right there it's it's a it's a
Sandbox that's it's a small sandbox
that's created specifically for you to
be able to manipulate it with the powers
you have at hand it's a different beast
when you say okay I'm gonna give you
those powers
but I'm going to give you an open world
to mess with is that world
malleable enough and and versatile
enough to be able to for that type of
gameplay to work right so this is this
is a different undertaking and that that
has to be respected you have to respect
that
all right so you know I think that's
pretty much all the questions that I got
for you guys you know first off we did
interview on what Cog you know briefly
talk about the interview that we did I'm
gonna put the interview he's about to
talk about in the description below in
case you guys want to go over there and
check that out and I'll do vice versa
from them over here yeah I mean shout
out to the legendary Harvey Smith we had
the pleasure of interviewing and he man
he dropped so many gems on the game and
uh yeah that will be up you'll check
that up it's so much stuff I do want to
do uh at one thing also in reference to
My overall Impressions with it at the
end was just that you know from me
coming from again not the Arcane you
know history but like as a as a fan of
of Cooperative Shooters what really
intrigues me about this is one it felt
fun too narratively I was interested as
to see what happened here in Redford
what is going on we didn't really talk
about the um the the vampire Gods
mechanic and how like things could
happen in this world they affect their
looking at what's going on and the more
you do they could send down some type of
Bruticus type figure or something to
come Chase The Rook The Rook you know
Maddie got a chance to experience that
so yeah I saw uh him and he looks like
um he looks like the Nemesis of Resident
Evil 3. yeah get a lot of Nemesis energy
you know a lot of things the safe houses
clearing stuff out you know other boss
fights and stuff that there's a lot we
didn't see yet so I want to be clear
with that second the other thing is that
you know from from me as the Cooperative
guy what intrigues me about red Falls
uniqueness is that like soft alluded to
which is the open world aspect I'm used
to Cooperative playing in stages okay we
did stage one stop go to stage two no
like this is open world this is and
again I'm not trying to throw any shade
on daily games I love y'all but like
this is what I was hoping State of Decay
2 did which was instead of us being
addict you go in there and I gotta stay
out front with the Jeep while you go in
there clear out the blood heart and I
can't go do my own thing like this is
all for the Lord's King can go down the
block I can go to another part of
Brooklyn everybody could do their own
thing no tether which is an IOP
exclusive
on our joint so go check out his words
where he fought for that he fought for
that the developers told him that is a
very big undertaking I don't know he's
like well we gonna have to figure this
out and for me that's exciting because I
want to see how that works now obviously
there's going to be scaling right you
know one person if we had that citizen
do addict you know just would try to do
too much you know he could get body
because of the scaling of what he's
going to deal with and he did say In
fairness that if Sinister example a
fictional person who don't listen to
know what to do with the group saying
and if that person go off fictional
person fictional Sinister I love you
brother but like that that goes off and
does his own thing and if he does
success with it he said like say if
there's a major story beat then there
will be a chance where they kind of will
bring us back together at a safe safe
house at that point but for the most
part it sounds open world and that part
really excites me I don't know why just
really I don't really I don't I guess
maybe Far Cry never been done before no
never never been done and I think
they're not getting enough credit there
so maybe the sacrifices from the skill
tree and the Arcane hardcore
sensibilities were made to try this new
thing and I'm willing to give them a
chance to see if it actually they can
execute land this plan because that part
is pretty exciting to me
yeah so it's like I said uh you know
first off I want to thank again Bethesda
you know for you know giving us the
opportunity to try this game you know
maybe we'll get some Let's Plays of the
Lord since there's ironically forces
yeah this is definitely this is
definitely a Community Day game
you know so like I said anyone that's
watching this in the description below
there'll be a link to the interview we
did I hope you guys enjoy all the
content we're giving on redfall and uh
until next time you know we will be at
Pax this coming up week but I hope you
guys have a good day and uh the Lords
are out peace let's let's be clear it's
the only interview with Harvey's
exclusive exclusive
[Laughter]
good to do it again real much love with
the support we got more content coming
for you and again thanks for the good
friends Bethesda and Arcane Austin for
give us the opportunity to cover it